while apocalypse is packed with the
Celestials allowed him to go forward
from Egypt as the most powerful
earthbound being at the time and forcing
civilizations around the world to
worship him as a God on the other side
of the Nile River and North East Africa
gods of a different sort were becoming
involved in the affairs of humanity
wanting the clock back to three billion
years ago following the banishment of
the Elder Gods Gaia who embodied the
Earth Spirit spawned children of her own
who took three forms the Titans the
Cyclops and the hectars
favored by their father array knows the
Titans embodied has left for battle in
his formidable strength testing one
another through physical combat the
Titans ruled from on high as their
brothers the Cyclops and hectares were
banished to the other dimensional realm
of Tartarus grieving for her children
Gaia besieged the Titans to destroy her
Raynaud's a task ignored by all but one
seeing the opportunity as a chance to
rule and taking up arms against his
father
the youngest Titan named Cronus
castrated him murdered array knows who
used his dying breath to curse Cronus
with death by his own son refusing to
honor the request of his mother to free
his brothers and seizing Mount Olympus
as his own
Cronus took a bride in the form of Rhea
who in turn gave birth to Zeus turning
against her son Gaia smuggled Zeus from
Olympus raising him to become a fierce
warrior growing into adulthood
Zeus freed the Cyclops and hectars
leading a march against Cronus and his
Titans defeating his father all the
Titans soldiers were banished to the
realm of Tartarus where they were
watched over by Hades allowing Zeus to
emerge as the king of gods turning his
sights to the Titan General Atlas Zeus
dispersed eagles across the earth
surveying his domain and locating the
center of the world Atlas was imprisoned
on the island of Atlantis doomed to
spend eternity holding the heavens on
its shoulders
becoming a home for the deviants
following the first experiments of the
Celestials the kingdom of Atlantis
served as a trading hub of the deviants
themselves and free men allowing sailors
and merchants to barter trinkets and
items from around the world spanning the
globe in reaching as far south as
Antarctica the Atlantean civilization
discovered the Savage Land as a place of
beauty
flora and fauna exporting animals from
around the globe
despite their advanced technology and
attempts at explaining how such a lush
jungle could exist in the Antarctic the
truth of the Savage Land eluded the
Atlanteans however during the deviants
battle with the Celestials the highly
advanced Atlantean civilization immersed
itself in spheres of unknown composition
under the belief that the conflict would
lay waste to the world bearing witness
as a deviant in celestial war shook the
skies and threatened to crack the earth
and to the island of Atlantis fell
beneath the surface where it would
remain hidden from those on land
as the ages passed and time allowed for
mankind to flourish on the surface
primitive tendencies gave way to a
reconstruction of organized society
constructing empires that grew through
conquest and were conquered in turn the
kingdom of Atlantis evolved as well with
all technology lost save for their
protective spheres and miscellaneous
instruments using their knowledge of
alchemy Atlantean priests began to
modify the genetic structure of their
people allowing for the ability to
breathe underwater remaining isolated
from the goings on in the surface this
time period of Atlantean history saw the
rise of two of history's most important
beings Meriden and Morgan la Fey
departing the kingdom of Atlantis and
taking up residence in Great Britain
where Morgan la Fey opposed the idea of
Britain transforming into a religious
Empire
Muradin supported the cause forming a
pact with Mordred the illegitimate son
of King Arthur Morgan la Fey SAW to
subvert Arthur's rule over Britain
capturing the kingdom of Camelot and
eventually the world invoking his
knowledge of alchemy mirrored in
rechristened himself Merlin and using
his magic to empower the ebony sword
selected Sir Percy of scandia to protect
the kingdom of Camelot operating as an
agent of both Merlin and King Arthur Sir
Percy of scandia defended Camelot on
several occasions saving the life of
King Arthur and securing his legacy as
one of Camelot's greatest warriors
however unbeknownst to King Arthur
Merlin or Sir Percy himself the ebony
blade had a will of its own forge
through combat and solidified through
bloodshed the ebony blade developed a
curse dimming all who wielded the sword
to a hunger for battle meeting his death
during the fall of Camelot the spirit of
Sir Percy endured appearing to all
descendants of his bloodline who were
found worthy of wielding the sword
moving away from britain within the
territories of both Africa and Egypt a
handful of second-generation gods had
formed their own followings originating
in Egypt proper unlike her counterparts
who maintained their ties to the
Egyptian culture the Panther God basked
elected to forge ties to both Egypt and
Africa worship within the Egyptian city
of Bubastis as the goddess of pleasure
the adoption of bast as an African
goddess did not occur until 10,000 years
ago hailing from the far side of the
universe whether through fate or divine
means a meteorite smashed into the
atmosphere scattering debris across the
planet while some landed in Antarctica
itself and various other territories
around the globe the largest fragment
made landfall on Wakanda discovered by
bachina who led a small band of nomads
the vibranium meteorite was believed to
be a gift from Africa's gods forging
weapons that utilize vibranium natural
ability to absorb sound and energy where
one half of the dschinghis tribe went
forward as the dominant group in africa
the other half were mutated to the
radiation permeated by the vibranium or
becoming demons of darkness and rage
praying to the african goddess dies to
aid his people
pachinko was bestowed with the powers of
the Panther God defeating the dark
demons serving as protector of wakanda's
vibranium stores but she get kept his
lands hidden from the world
all the while continuing to utilize the
powers of the black panther and becoming
the first in a line of descendants who
would share this role
while the small settlement of Wakanda
began his journey to become a kingdom
the various members of the second
generation of gods were becoming more
involved in the lives of mortal men
forming a Council of godheads known as
the sky fathers within the territories
of Greece India Scandinavia and North
America these sky fathers represented
the various religions of the world
ranging from Christianity and
Catholicism to Hinduism and Taoism
routinely interacting with humanity
albeit by indirect means not all who
were aware of this influence approved
returning to earth for a third time with
the intention of judging humanity's
evolution is worthy of continued
existence the Celestials were displeased
with the sky fathers influence on human
civilization bringing with them the
power to destroy the sky fathers with
but a thought the Council of godheads
were instructed to refrain from
involving themselves in the affairs of
mortal men lest they find their empires
destroyed and their lives forfeit as a
result the sky fathers grudgingly
honored this request for their legacies
fading from humanity's mind to be
replaced by myths and legend by the 12th
century humanity sat nestled in the
Middle Ages or this era would see the
rise of Genghis Khan who would go on to
form the largest empire in recorded
history at the time as well as the
tail-end of the religious Crusades one
of the most powerful mutants to have
ever existed was running headlong into
his destiny born to a wealthy French
family Bennett Dube Howie had wanted for
virtually nothing fighting in the
crusade as an adult during his travels
the pole of Destiny had revealed
whispers of an eternal Pharaoh in Egypt
capable of granting untold power driven
by ambition Bennett traveled to Egypt
after which he was met with a
disembodied voice asking if Bennett was
willing to sacrifice who he was to
become something better
his powers were awakened granting him a
level of telepathy and telekinesis
hitherto unchallenged forced to do
battle as a test of his abilities
Bennett Duke Henry emerged victorious
going forward as Exodus however
unbeknownst to Exodus his powers have
been awakened by apocalypse forced to do
battle against his allies exodus turned
on apocalypse proclaiming him a false
god
engaging in a battle against the tyrant
alongside his allies exodus was swiftly
overpowered after which he was sealed
away within a mountainside
while Exodus slumbered within his crypt
300 years past and saw the world
changing Europe was experiencing a
renaissance of art and science the Roman
Empire was collapsing and Joan of Arc
was turning the tide of the Hundred
Years War between England and France
during this time and within the mystic
city of Qom our Taj in the region of
Tibet on the western side of the
Himalayas
the world was met with the birth of Yama
spinning his youth as a peaceful farmer
yah was greeted by a fellow villager
named Kowloon exposing Yao to knowledge
of magic and sorcery the to journey
together through the realm of mystic
arts learning to control the wills of
men and harnessing the power of
immortality
however as Kalu expand his knowledge of
sorcery so too did he expand his lust
for power taking over the minds of local
farmers the maniacal tendencies of
colluded led to a battle between himself
in the AO laying waste to the city of
Khmer tache
Yao banished Kalu to the Crimson
dimension of citta rack after which the
out christened himself the ancient and
sought others like himself
it really has to do with talent I think
the people at marble who are making
these movies are the most talented movie
makers on the face of the planet they go
back to the roots of the comics and they
say what made this trip so successful
and once they decide what that element
or those elements may be they keep to
those elements they're starting out with
very colorful characters but if they put
them in the real world and they give
them real problems and everybody wants
to see it I I know the characters and I
can't wait to see the movies
em you see for me superheroes will
always spark the imagination of people
around the world regardless of their
background because I think that people
are always looking for something that
represents the ideal person or the ideal
situation one thing I might mention most
writers and I think it's an unfortunate
thing they try to write something that
they think a certain audience might
enjoy I've never been able to do that
because I can't put myself in the mind
of other people I only know what I enjoy
so every time I've written a story I've
always tried to write the sort of story
that I myself would enjoy reading a
story that would interest me while I'm
writing it as I'm waiting to find out
what happens next